Chris Mannix of Sports Illustrated back
here on the show how you doing Chris I'm
doing fine
I'm staying in Mike come in my role I'm
not I'm not tapping out I'm not telling
you and then telling my bosses later on
where we're staying put
I mean how bizarre in terms of all the
things that you've covered in your years
covering the NBA was this it was
probably the most shocking because you
know look it's not only the III think
it's probably the best job in the NBA
because you are overseeing the NBA's
marquee franchise and it was not one in
a state of disrepair I mean you have
LeBron James who had cap space you had
all your graphics you had solid young
players it was a disappointing year but
the cupboard isn't exactly bare in LA
and you've got carpet laws to do
whatever you want which magic basically
affirmed in that press gaggle the other
day and and there weren't really
glamorous first job either I mean
sometimes when guys are struggling in
the role you start talking about maybe
they'll step down you didn't hear any of
that when it came to magic so I've been
trying to think of something more
surprising and the NBA is certainly one
big soap opera after another but this
has to be at or near the very top of the
list well in your piece that you you
wrote about this episode this saga you
said essentially that this is an
opportunity and that Genie bus should
throw dollars in rose petals at the feet
of somebody else we're in the and a NBA
community that's done this before I'm
tell him to come run the Lakers for her
and it seems like she might not be doing
that as a matter of fact according to
Ramona Shelburne expanding the role of
Rob pálinka the general manager former
agent of of Kobe Bryant and as I should
also say Michigan Wolverine so what do
you what are you hearing about all this
Chris well I think we're still in in a
very wait-and-see mode right now I mean
if everything is accurate about how this
all went down
you know Jeannie Blas
her head that will be spinning a little
bit and you know empowering Rob the
Lincoln now it's obvious thing to do
there's not a lot to do right now you
know certain certainly draft workouts
you could start being organized and Rob
the like has done that before but
there's a little bit of room to kind of
make a consequential decision I would be
stunned if they don't at least look
outside the organization I mean they
have infinite resources they have as I
mentioned an appealing job maybe polenka
winds up being the guy his relationship
with the Lakers runs deep through fire
by extension of his feelings of the
agent of Kobe Bryant but I've been this
to me was Junie buses Mulligan like she
is she hired Magic Johnson and that was
fine and at the end of a sour you know
run with Jim bus and Mitch Kupchak it
felt like a reasonable thing to do now
she knows that she meets something
different and you know a lot of people
have written this and I agree with it
the Lakers are very much a
family-oriented business they've got to
go outside the family they're going to
take a blank check and send it to the
likes of Sam Presti
or Masai Ujiri or RC Buford somebody
that has done this job at a high level
in the past and I think would be open to
a Laker like opportunity if that isn't
done it to me is a catastrophic mistake
for the Lakers why are you allowed to do
that or is that tampering do you have to
have permission to do that I mean aren't
these folks that you just mentioned
locked into contracts Chris it's not
look it's not papering because you do
have to like there's are ways around you
don't think ask permission we hire
anybody under contract but I mean we
just heard all about this in the last
you know week about Washington and their
potential interest in Tim Conley the GM
of Denver Nuggets you can get around all
that now a team that has a guy under
contract is that the right to say no and
if they do eventually say yes they have
the right to ask for compensation which
I'm sure a top executives in the likes
of pricier jury would would
back in return but if you the Lakers who
cares like if it means giving up a
first-round pick down the line to get
Sam Presti you go and you do it a
hundred percent
same thing with Masai Ujiri or RC Buford
everybody looks at RC Buford as like
this this no San Antonio fixture for
light as anybody ever really asked him
to do something else like has anybody
offered him a whole bunch of money to
run his own team I wonder what he would
say in that particular situation Chris
Mannix of Sports Illustrated here in the
Rich Eisen show last one on this and I
guess it was perfectly timed Dwyane
Wade's finales the FIR LeBron to show up
and and be there for a friend because
you know I think a lot of people because
they always assume the worst when it
comes to LeBron in terms of being
power-hungry and needing to have the
control that he's out there a day after
all this happens living his own life
living his best life how much does he
have to do with this and what's going on
in LeBrons camp with two plus one years
left on his contract and this all
playing out mere weeks before the free
agency period that's the most crucial
potentially in his stay with the Lakers
final Harrah's yeah I don't think that
LeBron had anything to do with magic
decision to resign I think that what he
said at that press gaggle represented
you know a large percentage of why he he
chose to walk away but you know look he
just doesn't have the stomach to do this
on a daily basis the NBA it being such a
global game now you've gotta hop on
planes and slide you you know Croatia or
Russia to scout guys on a win that's
what all these GM's do I mean you saw
the documentary on Yanis over all-star
weekend John Hammond the GM of the Bucs
then just hopped on a plane when he
heard about this kid and went out and
scouted him and brought in to him at
that time enough to make him a mid
first-round draft pick so I don't think
magic had all that in him now LeBron has
put the Lakers kind of at a difficult
situation because if the broad wasn't
there you could certainly make an
argument that the Lakers were on a
pretty reasonable rebuilding track right
I mean they drafted very well over the
last couple of years
Kuzma was a terrific pic Josh Hart was a
terrific pic at the jury's kind of out
on LAN zone you can argue that Jason
Tatum and D Aaron Fox were the better
pic skyping Lonzo can become a starting
level high level NBA point guard but
because LeBron is there everything has
to be accelerated and you have to find a
way to piece together a winner that's
the ultimate conundrum for either Rob
palanca or the next GM that comes in
there do you build the team the right
way or do you try to you know cut and
paste together a contending type team in
the hopes that LeBron at age 34 can
still elevate that team to a
championship level team it's just it's a
quandary but I think the Lakers are in
because the right thing to do is to
build it slowly use your lottery pick
this year get the right guy you'll go
out try to sign a cop to your free agent
but if you don't get him don't overspend
on long-term contracts like they did in
the past with Timothy Mozgov and Luol
Deng well he runs that problem with
LeBron because he needs he's got two
years baby with the ability to lead a
team to a championship as the number one
guy and it's tough to make that work
last one for you Chris Mannix on the
future are you in the of the belief that
Kevin Durant the Knicks is a quote
unquote done deal I don't know anything
the done deal because ultimately the
Knicks have to sit in the room with them
and the Knicks have historically been
just bad when they do that they go back
to 2010 with all the free agent mating
meetings they took they were not
impressive in those meetings and yes
it's a new group and Scott Perry is
leading it Steve Mills is there but what
happens if James Dolan gets in the room
and screws it up I mean it it's possible
it's possible but I like you know like
everybody else rich I've been hearing
all along that strong leanings for Kevin
Durant go to York and I just can't
believe the Knicks would be crazy enough
crazies have been in the last two
decades
crazy enough to just give away kristaps
porzingis unless they knew that there
was a high chance to get Durant and a
pretty good chance they get to ranted
somebody else all right Chris Mannix
here on the Rich Eisen show I've got
Terry
coming up in our number three Marcus
smart apparently on the shelf four to
six weeks how do the Celtics enter this
first round series if you could best
describe it against the the Pacers -
Oladipo well I think they're still in
really good shape because as invaluable
as Marcus smart is they do have guys
that can fill that void to a degree and
they're playing Indiana and Indiana
they just can't score rips I was at a
glass Celtic taser game with a self it's
like the floor with them and you know
they've done some nice things with smoke
and mirrors to try to mask the absence
of Oladipo but they just can't score at
a level high enough to mean I think an
NBA playoff series so I think they get
through the first round but if smarts
missing in that second round and based
on the timeline the Celtics laid out at
four to six weeks it looks like he will
be they're gonna need everyone from
Jalen Brown to Gordon Hayward and Terry
Rozier I mean forgot talk to Terry about
this multiple times you know it's been a
hard year for him man he's really
struggled with this kind of reentry into
a backup role he's gone for being a
35-minute four game point guard in the
playoffs last year - you know playing
2530 minutes at both guard spots trying
to find a rhythm he's really strong he's
got a great teammate about it but he's
really struggled earnest this at least
in the first couple of rounds could be a
big opportunity for Terry Rozier because
he brings some defensive tenacity he
brings the kind of play making that
smart alecks that makes this could be a
chance for redemption to a degree
Patera in the post okay and his embiid
as suspect for answering the first round
Bell was Elton Brand might have laid out
there Chris what do you think I think
he's better I think he's very suspect
I've talked to a couple of people around
that situation and it's a lot of the
same stuff that yeah they think he's
gonna play how much he's going to play
and at what level he's going to play
remains incredibly unclear and you could
tell from the public comments from Elton
Brandon the frustration the backgrounds
never really frustrated he's kind of
saying like I'm done answering to LMB
quite
jeans right now that that told me
something you don't see a lot of that
from Brett round and I I'm start to get
the sense a lot of people on the league
started get the sense that this MV
meeting could be more problematic than
anyone is really letting on
so that's a game changer too I mean the
Nets have struggled identical Sixers at
full strength but if the sisters aren't
at full strength this is now a golden
opportunity for Brooklyn to advance in
the playoffs okay ask the poll question
of Chris Mannix before we send him into
into that good day Christopher yeah
Mannix he just kind of hit on one of the
matchup so what's the most intriguing
first-round matchup I went with these
four Celtics Pacers Sixers nets Rockets
Jaz Thunder boys yeah I go thunder
Blazers on that one the Thunder has the
matchup that they probably want because
without use of Newark it's the Blazers
are a significantly weaker team and if
they don't they can't be Portland I
don't know what this offseason looks
like but I don't think anything dramatic
happens but at the all-star break this
Thunder team looked like a real threat
to win the conference as appear they
were playing top ten level defense they
had two dynamic stars who could take
over the game in the fourth quarter Paul
George was playing like an MVP and then
you know really since February
they're shooting just full of a cliff
like they're putting up some gaps for
shooting numbers with George and
Westbrook and Dennis Schroder three of
their key offensive players kind of
leading the way in that charge so that
that's the most intriguing Portland can
they be kind of little engine that could
and Kenda Blazers their guards you know
carry the day and it's cancer can he
show up in the postseason against his
former team but for Oklahoma City
you got to win this series like you've
got to advance out of the first round if
you can't do it against a banged-up
blazer team you have to wonder exactly
who they're going to be able to do it
again oh boy alright last one for you
then Chris is the time line it for me
how do you see the time line here in Los
Angeles with Luke Walton and Jeanie buss
making a decision what's your best guess
on that
oh it's custard to read because until we
know what they're going to do with that
top executive position I don't know I
mean if they if the current regime stays
in place with Rob palanca effectively
being elevated I think Luke Waltons
gonna stay because that means Jeanie
buss is going to have a lot of influence
there and we know you know publicly and
privately what we know about you know
that gene really believes in Luke Walton
but if you're teeny bucks and you go
outside the organization and you hire
somebody that person has to have the
freedom to hire and fire their coach but
just that's the way that it has to be so
I think Luke Walton is far more
comfortable I mean I reported others did
that Luke was you know I hope he had his
office packed but he was ready to go at
the end of the season before this Magic
Johnson presser but I don't think he's
out of the woods yet in terms of being
their head coach next year Chris thanks
to the time we'll chat again real soon
enjoy the playoffs first round you got
to add s i Chris Mannix for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app